[Musica]
il 15 marzo del 2019 e stata una
giornata particolare i giovani sono
scese in tante piazze del mondo per
esprimere un messaggio di contrarietà
nei confronti dell'attuale sistema
energetico ancora troppo fondato su
fonti energetiche fossili
negli ultimi mesi le tematiche
ambientali sono notista di tutti i
giorni non c'è notiziario che
quotidianamente non parli di eventi
metereologici a volte sulle prime pagine
dei giornali vengono riportati dai
titoli un po provocatorie scettici nei
confronti dei cambiamenti climatici
associando ondate di freddo fuori
stagione come quella che si è verificata
nelle scorse settimane che ha portato
neve e ghiaccio o gelate tardive a quote
collinari ed è sicuramente un evento
eccezionale fuori stagione ma non si può
associare un'ondata di freddo
all'annullamento degli effetti dei
cambiamenti climatici
molto spesso ci si dimentica della
differenza che c'è tra il meteo e il
clima gli eventi metereologici sono
episodi locali e limitati nel tempo
mentre gli eventi climatici il clima il
prima valuta il tempo su un più lungo
spettro su una regione su un area su una
nazione infatti si parla di
riscaldamento del pianeta
in ogni caso grazie alle manifestazioni
dei giovani il mese di marzo di
quest'anno può essere considerata una
linea di demarcazione una presa di
coscienza sul fatto che occorre
intervenire occorre porre dei
cambiamenti all'attuale sistema di
sviluppo e consumo di energia
il prossimo appuntamento sullo sciopero
mondiale per il futuro è fissato tra due
giorni il 24 maggio del 2019
questi eventi la loro intensità e
frequenza ci fanno toccare con mano un
problema enorme una crisi ambientale
definita da molti ormai irreversibile
ovviamente questa irreversibilità va
vista nell'ordine di grandezza della
vita
un uomo quello che si può e si deve fare
è intervenire per mitigarne gli effetti
perché non abbiamo un'alternativa non
abbiamo un secondo pianeta
in realtà probabilmente la prima presa
di coscienza venne nel 1968 quando un
torinese aurelio peccei decise di
fondare il club di roma un'associazione
no profit che all'epoca riunì scienziati
economisti e personalità rilevanti di
tutti i cinque continenti
la missione era quella di individuare i
principali problemi che l'umanità si
sarebbe trovato ad affrontare cercando
di identificare soluzioni alternative ai
diversi scenari possibili
dopo quattro anni nel 1972 club di roma
pubblico un rapporto dal titolo i limiti
dello sviluppo dove metteva in evidenza
le problematiche che alle quali si
sarebbe andati incontro nei prossimi
decenni se il modello di sviluppo non
fosse cambiato vagliano un anno alla
fine dell'ottobre nell'ottobre del 1973
avvenne un improvviso aumento dei prezzi
del petrolio i prezzi del greggio
aumentarono di oltre quattro volte
decretando quella che tutti oggi
ricordiamo come la crisi energetica del
1973 quella crisi stimolo alla ricerca
di nuove fonti alternative al greggio i
governi dei paesi industrializzati
occidentali iniziarono a varare
provvedimenti nell'ottica della
riduzione dei consumi energetici e negli
anni successivi l'efficienza di utilizzo
dell'energia incomincio a documentare e
allo stesso tempo continua ad aumentare
la sensibilizzazione sulle tematiche
ambientali sulle problematiche
ambientali nel 1988 venne fondato lippi
si si
un gruppo intergovernativo sul
cambiamento climatico fondato da due
organismi delle nazioni unite
l'organizzazione meteorologica mondiale
ed il programma delle nazioni unite per
l'ambiente
lo scopo principale dell ipi sì sì è
quello di
studiare i cambiamenti climatici e del
riscaldamento globale il riscaldamento
del pianeta viene a causa principalmente
dall'aumento della concentrazione di un
gas considerato climalterante il
principale gas ad effetto serra
l'anidride carbonica formula chimica co2
l'anidride carbonica non è un gas
pericoloso dannoso per l'uomo anzi
permette la vita sulla terra permette
delle condizioni vivibili sulla terra il
problema sta nel fatto che quando questo
gas
la concentrazione di questo gas aumenta
fortemente è correlata un aumento a un
aumento della temperatura da un aumento
della temperatura avvengono con maggiore
intensità e potenza agli eventi
meteorologici
nel 2004 si è conclusa un progetto di
ricerca europeo chiamato progetto epica
sia perché è stata un'impresa epica sia
perché epica significa european project
ice core antartica e questo progetto ha
permesso di ricostruire la
concentrazione di anidride carbonica
sulla terra negli ultimi 800 mila anni
da poche settimane si parla già del
progetto oltre epica che permetterà di
ricostruire la concentrazione di
anidride carbonica fino a un milione e
mezzo di anni fa nel progetto epica e
stato perforato uno spessore di ghiaccio
della colonna del continente
dell'antartide di 3.270 metri ed è stata
rilevata la concentrazione di anidride
carbonica nelle particelle d'aria
contenute nel ghiaccio stesso
il risultato è quello che vediamo nel
grafico ovvero che negli ultimi 800 mila
anni la concentrazione di anidride
carbonica non aveva mai superato il
valore delle 300 parti per milione
oggi siamo sopra le 400 circa 415 parti
per milione in questo valore cresce ad
un valore di quasi due parti per milione
se consideriamo che l'uomo sapiens è
comparso si è sviluppato sulla terra
circa 300 mila anni fa oggi stiamo
vivendo una terra dalle condizioni
chimiche mai vista in precedenza
solamente negli ultimi 150 200 anni di
rivoluzione industriale abbiamo fatto un
salto che ci ha spostato dalle 300 alle
oltre 400 parti per milione di anidride
carbonica in atmosfera
i responsabili di questo incremento
siamo principalmente noi attraverso la
combustione dei combustibili fossili ma
pensiamo a cosa facciamo tutti i giorni
viviamo un'abitazione questa deve essere
climatizzata andiamo a scuola al lavoro
ci spostiamo e consumiamo energia per
lavorare e studiare mangiare consumiamo
energia solamente a stare seduti in
questo teatro stiamo consumando energia
i nostri stili di vita influenzano il
consumo energetico vestirsi
adeguatamente in funzione delle stagioni
è vero che non esistono più le mezze
stagioni ma il 40 per cento dell'energia
che viene consumata è consumata
all'interno degli edifici e questa fetta
è fortemente influenzata dai nostri
stili di vita
il fatto che ogni azione che svolgiamo
comporti un consumo energetico e la
realtà occorre solamente esserne
coscienti al fine di intraprendere le
migliori soluzioni che è possibile
intraprendere ma l'energia che
utilizziamo tutti i giorni la benzina al
distributore del gas e l'elettricità a
casa come fanno ad arrivare li cerchiamo
di ripercorrere ripercorrere in ordine
il percorso
innanzitutto l'energia deve essere
prodotta e per quanto riguarda i
combustibili fossili deve essere
estratta se pensiamo il petrolio che ne
vengono e stati quasi 100 milioni di
barili ogni giorno oppure al gas
naturale bene questi due combustibili
possono essere estratti da delle
piattaforme come quella raffigurata in
figura mentre per quanto riguarda il
carbone le modalità di estrazione sono
differenti ma gli effetti di una
massiccia estrazione dal sottosuolo
possono essere questi il fenomeno della
subsidenza se io tolgo del materiale dal
sottosuolo quello che c'è sopra
sprofonda quindi dopo che le fonti
primarie sono state estratte necessario
trasportare dai luoghi di produzione ai
luoghi di utilizzo attraverso delle
tubazioni per esempio dei gasdotti degli
oleodotti
nell'attesa di essere distribuiti agli
utilizzatori finali che siamo a noi
necessario accumularli affinché un
sistema energetico sia affidabile
ovvero che garantisca un
approvvigionamento energetico è
necessario che si disponga di riserve di
energia sia per motivi ambientali perché
potrebbe verificarsi un inverno
particolarmente freddo che ci fa
consumare più energia di quella che
abbiamo consumato previsto di consumare
oppure per motivi legati ai fornitori
perché se decidessero di interrompersi
la fornitura beh ci metterebbero in
difficoltà quindi fino adesso abbiamo
parlato di fonti fossili tradizionali
che vengono prodotte a partire
dall'estrazione ma l'elettricità non
esiste in natura non è possibile
estrarla dal sottosuolo
abbiamo però la possibilità di produrla
attraverso diverse fonti primarie con le
tradizionali molte altre il sole l'acqua
il vento i consumi di energia elettrica
crescono costantemente perché è più
facile produrre l'energia elettrica
dalle fonti rinnovabili che il petrolio
dalle fonti rinnovabili
e poi perché l'energia elettrica è la
forma più nobile di energia che esiste
ed è facile trasformarla se pensiamo
bene possiamo generare del calore
attraverso delle classiche resistenza
elettrico oppure utilizzando delle
macchine un po più efficienti le pompe
di calore possiamo produrre del freddo
possiamo utilizzare i motori elettrici e
muoverci i treni con gli autoveicoli
l'elettricità però ha un grande problema
non può essere accumulata con facilità
come per il petrolio lo mettiamo in un
serbatoio oppure gas naturale lo
rimettiamo nel sottosuolo nei vecchi
giacimenti di gas naturale ormai esausti
l'elettricità deve essere prodotta
quando serve questo grafico raffigura la
potenza elettrica che in questo momento
in italia stiamo consumato
sono le undici meno un quarto il nostro
gestore della rete elettrica nazionale
per oggi aveva previsto un consumo pari
a 35 mila megawatt
questo significa che in questo momento
vi sono delle centrali idroelettriche
termoelettriche ed altre tipologie che
stanno producendo esattamente quella
potenza ma ritornando al tema
dell'accumulo se mi riscaldo con la
legna
cosa faccio durante il periodo estivo
faccio una bella scorta affinché ne
abbia sufficienza per tutto l'inverno
fare questo per l'energia elettrica non
è possibile
o meglio non è possibile farlo in modo
semplice in questo momento tutti in
tasca abbiamo un accumulatore di energia
elettrica il cellulare nel possiede uno
la batteria
ma il nostro sistema elettrico nazionale
quali accumoli possiede
beh attualmente la rete elettrica
nazionale
possiede i bacini alpini ecco che sono
il suo accumulatore e appunto agli
impianti idroelettrici per pompaggio
funzionano esattamente così possiedono
un bacino di monte un bacino di valle e
trasferiscono l'acqua dal bacino di
montalbano di varia a seconda se la rete
elettrica nazionale necessita di
immissione di elettricità in rete oppure
se ne possiede un surplus ne assorbono
per trasferire l'acqua dal bacino di
valle al bacino di monte aggiungere
nuovi grandi bacini può essere
complicato quello che però forse può
essere fatto in modo più semplice
estendere la metodologia di generazione
distribuita che si è fortemente diffusa
con gli impianti fotovoltaici
all'accumulo distribuito pensate quando
il numero di auto elettrica aumenterà
fortemente ogni auto avrà una batteria e
quella batteria e un accumulatore di
energia elettrica
il nostro sistema energetico per poter
aumentare la sua quota di energia
prodotta dalle fonti rinnovabili e per
aumentare la sua affidabilità e di
conseguenza la sua sicurezza deve
necessariamente aumentare la sua
capacità di accumulare l'energia
prodotta dalle fonti rinnovabili e
possedere un adeguato mix di generazione
il mix il mix energetico è
importantissimo perché il fatto di
approvvigionare l'energia da fonti
differenti
e se pensiamo in particolare alle fonti
rinnovabili cerca di ridurre in modo
naturale al problema dell'aleatorietà
della fonte
il problema più grosso da risolvere è la
discontinuità di produzione di energia
da fonte rinnovabile e la non piena
corrispondenza tra la domanda e
l'offerta il sole c'è di giorno ma noi
l'elettricità la vogliamo anche di notte
in una giornata nuvolosa o piovosa
ripensando limitatamente ai consumi
elettrici e necessario approvvigionarsi
da fonti differenti per esempio l'eolico
il fotovoltaico
quindi la sorgente solare la sorgente
terra la geotermia all'acqua
l'idroelettrico avere la possibilità di
programmare la produzione energetica è
fondamentale se non è possibile farlo
accendendo e spegnendo i sistemi di
generazione perché non sempre il vento e
il sole ci sono è necessario cercare di
accumulare l'energia quando è possibile
produrla per poterla utilizzare quando
non è possibile produrla a scapito di
una perdita di energia stessa
in ogni caso già oggi il nostro sistema
elettrico possiede una buona percentuale
di energia elettrica prodotta dalle
fonti rinnovabili storicamente basata
sugli impianti idroelettrici ma che
negli ultimi anni ha avuto una forte
spinta grazie agli impianti fotovoltaici
ed eolici la percezione di molte persone
forse un po scettiche al cambiamento è
quella di sostenere che i pannelli
solari
oppure le auto elettriche che possiedono
una batteria siano tecnologie più
inquinanti dall'utilizzare sin dal
principio una risorsa non rinnovabile in
realtà prestigiosi studi di ricerca
hanno mostrato che i pannelli solari
fotovoltaici nei primi anni di vita
generano tutta l'energia che è stata
necessaria alla loro fabbricazione
mentre per quanto riguarda le auto
elettriche possiamo vedere in questo
esempio come a parità di veicolo
cambiato solamente l'alimentazione
facendola passare da gasolio all'energia
elettrica acquistata dalla rete
elettrica nazionale non ovviamente
prodotta da un generatore a combustione
interna come quello
raffigurato in figura bene solamente
cambiando l'alimentazione è possibile
ridurre di un terzo le missioni che sono
considerate emissioni climalteranti
ovverosia le emissioni di anidride
carbonica per chilometro percorso
si riducono di un terzo quindi
tralasciando le problematiche relative
all'autonomia dell'auto elettrica che
verranno risolte nel prossimo futuro
spostare i consumi di energia dalle
fonti fossili alle fonti rinnovabili
all'elettricità stessa prodotto delle
fonti rinnovabili è possibile e meno
impattante sull'ambiente
quindi abbiamo visto che noi siamo i
principali responsabili siamo quelli che
influenzano fortemente i consumi
energetici ed è necessario che
sfruttiamo la possibilità che abbiamo di
cambiare
ognuno con le proprie possibilità anche
economiche deve fare la propria parte
abbiamo visto che il sistema energetico
e complesso da gestire le fonti
rinnovabili sono aleatorie alcune hanno
una stagionalità anche marcata ma già
oggi vi sono tecnologie che ci
permettono di avere alti standard di
benessere impattando meno sull'ambiente
niels bohr diceva che fare le previsioni
è difficile soprattutto sul futuro
quello che però sappiamo è che se
continuiamo attraverso l'utilizzo
massiccio di combustibili fossili il
nostro unico pianeta sarà sempre più
malato ed a pagarne le conseguenze
saremo noi e le generazioni future
la fonte più rinnovabile che abbiamo
sorge tutti i giorni gratuitamente da
quella che occorre utilizzare
[Applauso]
[Musica]